welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
complete Walking Dead recap of Maggie
and Negan before their new show dead
City we first meet Maggie in season two
when the group comes to her father
herschel's Farm she's a cool competent
farm girl who's a get stuff done type
she pairs up with our group's nice guy
Glenn and when they go out Scavenging
they find some condoms she's like hey
boy you're cute let's get it on they got
a fun thing going the country girl and
the city boy and pretty soon they've
fallen in love when the Farm's overrun
the group comes to the prison where
Glenn finds a diamond ring and these two
get apocalypse married but now they face
off against the governor who takes some
hostages including her father Herschel
and ow now he kills him when the
prison's overrun she and Glenn get
separated and go on an epic journey to
find each other finally they do but
Maggie's younger sister Beth gets caught
up in the hospital Arc at the end of
which she dies oh no Maggie now she's
lost all her family the group goes
through their darkest days yet but they
come out the other side at Alexandria
now that they're safe Maggie and Glenn
plan for the future and they're gonna
have a baby soon they meet a new
community Hilltop where Maggie steps up
in a leadership role taking point
associating with their slimy leader
Gregory but then our groups captured by
a ruthless gang led by the man himself
it's Negan he's gonna let them live so
they can pay him tribute but to show
he's serious he's got to kill one of
them well first he picks Abraham but
then to show he's really serious he's
gotta kill one more and oh no this one
is Glenn no not Glenn yes he brutally
kills Maggie's husband in front of her
so brutal in fact I know this is where a
lot of you stopped watching the show now
Negan is an interesting character he's
adopted this Persona where he can't just
say a line he has to say a line and he's
got a funny way of standing always
leaning back like he's on the verge of
falling over his gang is called the
savior is because he thinks of himself
as a good guy who's bringing
civilization back to the zombie
apocalypse but he's not a good guy he's
a megalomaniac that enjoys lording his
power over people he has his own code
though he's a real stickler for the
rules uh if you break any iron to the
face he has a soft spot for kids though
when Carl tries to kill him he cooks
some spaghetti for adults though
absolutely no mercy so Maggie Mourns
Glenn and makes her new home at Hilltop
because they have a a baby doctor here
she wants Hilltop to rise up and fight
Negan but the current leader Gregory's a
coward in fact Maggie starts to show
that she's a better leader and soon the
people of Hilltop elect her later
Gregory tries to kill her which doesn't
work out well for him and by this point
she'd given him multiple Second Chances
so Maggie finally hangs him so our good
communities band together to fight Negan
in all out War it's a season-long
gunfight with lots of ins and outs but
eventually Rick cow gets Negan but Rick
doesn't kill him he sentences him to
life in prison to show that this new
world can be merciful Maggie does not
agree with this decision she busts in to
kill Negan herself but when she sees how
much he hates confinement she changes
her mind leaves him here to rot but
Maggie's ready to start somewhere Fresh
So when she meets this woman Georgie
who's traveling around trying to help
out other communities Maggie's like yeah
let me roll with now we have a time Jump
negan's better adjusted to his life in
captivity found a new purpose as the
funny man who lives under the stairs in
fact the group has gotten lazy one day
they don't lock his cell so the Negan is
friggin he thinks about restarting the
saviors but the world's different now
he's different now looking back on the
Negan that he used to be he rely is now
yeah I was kind of cringe we eventually
get a flashback to when he was a
normalish dude who was living with his
wife Lucille that he later named his Bat
after and he was a good guy who was
working overtime helping her survive the
zombie apocalypse and cancer eventually
though of course she died which kinda
broke him and he adopted his Negan
Persona and accepted that violence was
the only way but now Negan wants to be
good again and The Walking Dead's
biggest villain is gonna try for a
Redemption Arc he saves Judith crimes
during a blizzard so they let him out of
his cell for good behavior but then he
accidentally killed someone which
violates his parole and now they're
gonna execute him so instead he escapes
again and goes to see the current
villain Alpha and the whisperers like
hey they want to kill me so let's be
friends so Negan learns how to walk with
the dead and quickly Rises the ranks to
be Alpha's new favorite in fact one day
they get it on and the zombie mask does
not come off but he only got close to
her so he could kill her yes an
undercover mission that was Carol's idea
in exchange Negan would be an accepted
part of the group now anyone who was
there at the lineup will never forgive
him but they do accept that he's on
their side now but just then Maggie
comes back none pleased to see him
walking around free she's been on a wild
Journey with her and Glenn's super cute
son little Herschel but now she's come
back to rejoin our group her first
thought is to kill Negan immediately so
these two are off to a Rocky new start
but with other threats out there soon
May accept they have to work together to
survive and as fate keeps putting these
two together they start to become a
pretty good team negan's like look mags
you missed it but I've had a Redemption
Arc but he does not apologize for
killing Glenn in fact he stands by it
does the right decision at the time so
yeah Maggie still hates him they realize
this group ain't big enough for both of
them so Negan leaves to find a new one a
short time later Maggie faces off
against the Commonwealth she helps a new
group defend against them and wouldn't
you know it there's Negan and when her
son Herschel is captured it's Uncle
Negan who busts in to save him but Whoa
Don't Call Him Uncle Negan that's the
psycho who killed my father negan's like
yeah kids sorry about that so they put
this beef on hold now saving her son
goes a long way for Maggie to start
trusting Negan Moore and in fact Negan
has a family now because he got
apocalypse married and his wife's
already pregnant eventually the
Commonwealth captures them and Negan
finds himself on his knee is about to be
executed with his wife an unborn child
they end up getting saved but now Negan
understands what he put Maggie through
by killing Glenn he finally says those
magic words I'm so sorry look man thanks
for finally saying sorry except that
you're a better person now and I even
trust you but I can never fully forgive
you so Negan comes to realize Redemption
isn't some Arc he completes it's
something he'll spend the rest of his
life doing so as the group is set to
live happily ever after Negan realizes
his presence will always make things
awkward so he graciously leaves but
turns out Maggie is leaving too there's
still a lot of other communities out
there that need her help and she's gonna
go help him and so somehow Maggie and
Negan will have to team up once again
for a new adventure in New York in their
new series dead City if you like this
recap hit that subscribe button for more
of the best Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]